[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's olympic
bobsledder alana myers tater made
history for team usa in beijing she won
a silver and a bronze medal becoming the
winter games most decorated black
athlete ever myers-taylor has won five
medals in four olympics and has meddled
in every event she's ever competed in
wow other members of team usa chose her
to carry the american flag at the
closing ceremony oh i love seeing you do
that and this was also her first
olympics as a mom to her two-year-old
son nico alana myers taylor good morning
congratulations we were laughing in the
commercial break because she was having
trouble sorting all of these medals
because she's got so many she's a little
stooped
those things are heavy now
elana how does it feel has it sunken in
you've broken this huge barrier how are
you doing this morning oh i'm doing
great and it definitely has not sunk in
and i don't know when it will we're just
riding a high right now just super
excited for the results this past couple
weeks but uh yeah it's just a crazy
whirlwind what i love about your story
is that you never considered bobsledding
until your parents told you about
vanetta flowers who was the first black
athlete to win a gold medal in the
winter games if you hadn't had a
representative a role model that looked
like you do you think you'd be sitting
here right now oh absolutely not i think
seeing is believing and you see somebody
who looks like you and vanetta is also
from birmingham in the south i'm from
georgia so seeing that representation
definitely is something that allowed me
to believe that winter sport could be
for me the most decorated black athlete
in winter olympics history she asked if
it sunk in but what does it mean to hear
that that title that statement can be
said proudly and loudly
yeah you know i didn't even know it was
uh it was something i was going for or
anything like that i didn't know i'd be
up for running because when you think
about
amazing black olympians you think about
the shawnee davis you think about
vanetta flowers you think about all
these aaron jackson now and all these
people have come before you like i
didn't know it was even a thing that i'd
be close to so for me it's really about
that representation and really about
leaving a legacy for more people to get
into winter sport because winter sport
is really for all and i think sometimes
when we see it we think it's as wide as
the snow and we don't believe it's for
everybody but it can be for everybody if
there was gold medals handed out for
being a host gayle king would have a
bunch of them and she's in los angeles
and she wanted to chime in they're
called emmys and she does have oh she
doesn't you're right yeah she has a
bunch of images
i did i did alana myers taylor hello i'm
so sorry i'm on assignment in l.a
because i really wanted to meet you in
person all i can say is i'm not worthy
i'm not worthy i'm not worthy but but
before you came alana you'll like this
nate i love how you described her alana
he said this about you super mom super
athlete superwoman so i'm wondering do
you feel like a superwoman and please
say yes you do
at times i do i think that's the thing
about being a parent and being a mom is
sometimes you feel like oh i'm not good
enough oh you know things aren't going
smoothly but the thing the way i look at
it as each and every single day i just
try and go out there and be the best
person i can try to be the best
representative i can and some days are
better than others but as long as my
son's happy as long as i'm doing the
best i can i know i'm going to be
winning
i think we have no idea
yeah yeah some days here we all know
what that means we all have children at
the table we know what it like means
some days are better than us oh your
husband and your son are there whoa
nico's in the studio
wow
alana you have shared a lot about nico
go ahead go ahead adriana well exactly
that gail you know tell us about your
son and how you say that it's made you
stronger i mean i feel like motherhood
it just makes you a better version of
who you are right and my son nico is
absolutely the greatest so after he was
born we received a diagnosis of down
syndrome um he has down syndrome and
profound hearing loss so over the course
of his life he's overcome so many
challenges and fortunately for this
olympics i was able to donate my opening
ceremony jacket to the national down
syndrome society
and we raised 5 000 one dollars and one
of my partners bridgestone they believe
in family community all these types of
things they actually doubled the
donation so uh ten thousand and two
dollars so to speak they double the
donation to national down syndrome
society and i wanted to use my olympic
platform to really showcase him and
showcase all the people in the
disability community and how much work
they go through day in and day out to
have the greatest lives possible elana i
know it's still sinking in but what's
next
i have no idea
that's a good answer that's a great
answer
more medals yes more battles hopefully
we'll see where i go from an athletic
standpoint but definitely going to enjoy
being a mom for a little bit yeah enjoy
you deserve it thank you so much alana
myers taylor thank you